les métiers liés aux odeurs ne se limite
pas à la parfumerie
c'est le message que souhaitez faire
passer les organisateurs du congrès
olfaction et perspectives qui se tenait
ce jeudi à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie c'est aussi surtout de
parler des nouveaux champs d'application
de l'olfaction comme on l'a dit c'est un
sens qui était pas mal oublié jusqu'à
aujourd'hui alors qu'en fait c'est un
sens qui va nous permettre finalement de
pouvoir ouvrir de nouveaux métiers d'une
grande ouverture en tout cas pour nos
jeunes aussi non seulement dans les
métiers classiques de parfumerie la
cosmétique ou dans l'alimentaire mais
aussi on l'a vu dans le domaine médical
où on verra dans le domaine de
l'environnement
parmi les avancées présentées la
détection de maladies par les odeurs ou
encore le lien entre émotion et odeurs
appliquée aux biens de consommation si
on veut positionner un produit comme
étant relaxant une crème ya 30 quand
même temps relaxante
on pourrait aussi proposer un parfum qui
aille dans ce sens là émotionnellement
pour renforcer et suggéré d'autant plus
ce pouvoir par exemple relaxant de la
crème c'est un peu ça l'idée
donc finalement pour nous en tant que
fabricant de parfums et d'arômes sait
sélectionner nos produits en fonction de
certains positionnements émotionnel
finaux des biens de consommation et des
produits de consommation les yvelines
représente un territoire clé de ce
secteur
500 entreprises de cosmétiques y sont
implantées ainsi que l'école isipca
créée en 1970 par jean paul guerlain
lui-même la région ile de france fait
également partie de la cosmetic valley
avec les régions normandie et centre
d'abord un impact d'attractivité et dans
le monde n'y a rien de mieux donc c'est
un peu une silicon valley dans lesquels
encres est en fait un mouvement qui
associé à la fois la recherche la
formation les pme la cosmetic valley
représente 18 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires et prévoit 1500 création
d'emplois d'ici 2015